face the nation moderator and senior
foreign affairs correspondent Margaret
Brennan is here with CBS News senior
global affairs contributor Ian Bremmer
he is the president of the Eurasia group
good morning to you both President Trump
said today he didn't give up anything
and yet he said he would suspend these
joint military exercises with the South
Koreans this morning the South Koreans
responded by saying we're trying to
figure out exactly what Trump meant is
this a big concession it is it's
tremendous to have the South Koreans say
this because they are our partners our
allies in those military exercises the
Pentagon has also not said is this a
halt a suspension an end how long does
this last I mean there are so many
details that we don't know in terms of
this nebulous security guarantee that's
mentioned here in this statement does it
go beyond that the president has at
least three times been asked by
reporters since that press conference
what else did you promise in terms of
security guarantees and he will not go
into it it's gonna be up to Mike Pompeo
was flying at China and South Korea to
work out the details more details in the
United States has made agreements with
North Korea in the past 1994 2005 2012
the North Koreans have this great
strategy they string us along they ring
out new economic stuff and then it's
just talk and they could continue their
nuclear weapons program why should we
believe them now we shouldn't believe
them and I mean it's a little surprising
to see Trump say I trust the guy it's
more of a stronger formulation than Bush
looking into Putin's eyes and saying I
saw a soul might live to regret that but
Kim jong-un is a different leader a
younger leader focusing more on the
economic engagement and the openness
he's done over the course of the past
few months with the South Koreans summit
twice now with the South Korean
president twice with Xi Jinping once
with the Russian for minister lavrov
going to Pyongyang and now Trump that's
the story here's that the North Koreans
are opening up and Trump as a piece of
it let's keep in mind what we now have
is a freeze for freeze it is the North
Koreans are freezing their ICBM and
nuclear tests and the Americans are
freezing our military exercises with the
South Koreans that is exactly the
formation of the Chinese have asked for
over the course of the past year and
we've said absolutely not margit let me
ask you about this key question of
denuclearization in the in the agreement
as I read it it is just a react for
of it point number three a reaffirmation
of a previous promise that the North
Koreans have made to work toward work
towards the crucial fact working towards
as opposed to agreeing to so put that in
context for us what exactly was agreed
to here that the North Koreans have not
already previously agreed to on nukes
well we don't know what we know from the
president said is that they've started
to break apart some of their missiles
that's part of the irreversible step he
wanted to see Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo is flying to these Asian capitals
to explain what happened in the room but
he's gonna have to brief Congress
they're gonna be a lot of questions
about exactly what that means I think
one of the interesting things is if you
take a step back it took two years of
direct talks with Iran to get them to
[ __ ] about 97% of their enriched uranium
break up thousands of their centrifuges
and hold their program and they didn't
have anything like the arsenal that we
know and believe North Korea has and
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo as a
congressman raised holy hell about that
deal so he has set for himself and a
tremendous benchmark as a president
Trump in terms of what they now need to
get in terms of details access to
military sites actual American
inspectors on the ground we know that's
what America wants we don't know if
that's what they got agreed to in this
room we know that's what John Bolton has
said he wants American inspectors to be
taking the lead to break apart these
weapons so that it doesn't happen again
that they don't cheat like they have in
the past so what stood out to both of
you in this agreement that we've reached
today and is there a win for both sides
look I think what the biggest win is
that six months ago we were talking
about the possibility of military
preemption against North Korea
it's almost inconceivable now that there
is a short-term risk of military
conflict that's a win for the North
Korean and the South Korean people first
among all but also Trump has gotten this
historic summit he did get the Chinese
to squeeze the North Koreans harder on
sanctions the North Koreans came to the
table before Trump started that the only
foreign leader Kim jong-un did mammoth
was Dennis Rodman right so let's there
is something historic that here is it is
important but as Margaret suggested it's
a very high bar to go from here to
complete verifiable irreversible
denuclearization and the North Koreans
didn't actually take any concrete step
towards that yesterday what
that the president dangled today was the
removing of some 30,000 US troops that
have been in the Korean Peninsula
I lived there it has a kid you know miss
is a long time that we've had a
commitment to that area if we were to
remove troops from the Korean Peninsula
it doesn't just affect the Korean
Peninsula affects our entire military
strategic posture in Asia doesn't it
isn't that really what China wants and
this is exactly not only what Ian
highlighted there in terms of the freeze
first freeze language that China wanted
this is what China wants North Korea
isn't the only flashpoint in Asia as you
point out there are a lot of concerns
about clashes in South China Sea also a
big winner here at South Korea's moon
jae-in because he was looking
desperately for an off-ramp he was very
concerned about this ratcheting up of
military tensions and he delivered he
pulled off this coup of getting these
South Korean intelligence officers into
the oval office back in March to brief
the president the president said today
and this was interesting I've had a
relationship with Kim jong-un for about
90 days that takes you back to March he
hasn't said if he's spoken to him before
talked on the phone is that what you're
saying it seems to me that's what he may
be dancing around there we've had a
relationship for 90 days I've been to 90
days what about when he was saying I
trust him what about the personal
chemistry between the two I mean they
both seem to enjoy this photo op the the
way that they touched each other the way
that they smiled at each other you know
this goes from really very personal
name-calling
that wasn't so long ago look I mean you
remember the way the Kim show that the
North Korean leader his father was
portrayed in Team America I'm so lonely
I mean you know both Trump and Kim are
leaders that clearly really want some
legitimization right they want to be
treated well but I would just say the
most important takeaway here long-term
is that the United States is probably
going to be a much more marginal player
at the end of the day in this region and
you know in the same way that Syria kind
of defined the Obama administration he
ultimately wasn't that major play in the
ground
that's kind of what we're seeing here
China's the big winner much more to talk
about Ian Brown there and Mark Brennan
thank you so much